What this line does that the other ones don't do, it maximizes the distance to
the nearest point, and it does this relative to both classes.
It's a line that maximizes the distance to the nearest points in either class,
that distance is often called margin.
If you go to a machine learning party, and
everybody talks about support vector machines.
It's really good to know the word margin because it is the thing that is
being maximized.
The margin is the distance between the line and
the nearest point of either of the two classes.
Is this because it's more simple? It's in line with an axis.
Did I just pick the line at random or is something else going on over here?
Is there some criterion that would make you pick this line,
over the other two lines that I gave you